human beings are often crippled by doubt
we are choking on our intro versions we
are looking for someone to believe in I
recently came across a phrase that spoke
of the infectiousness of the
unconflicted man why do we find certain
individuals so compelling why do we find
certain orators so irresistible
what is this infectiousness of the
unconflicted man what makes somebody a
visionary what makes somebody a leader
that inspires a kind of manic following
and I believe it is precisely the
conviction with which they communicate a
vision that is unconflicted because
we're all looking for certainty right
that's that great line that says we're
all falling through space no one knows
what's going on and there's nothing to
hold down to and therefore we're
grasping for some kind of certainty
we're grasping for some kind of
conviction were grasping for someone
that claims to know the infectiousness
of the unconflicted man is what makes a
movie star so compelling what makes a
talented preacher so addicting what
makes a compelling writer so difficult
to put to bed for the infectiousness of
the unconflicted man is the invitation
into drinking the kool-aid so to speak
and providing ourselves with a kind of
eggs
essential reassurance that we need in
order to sleep at night for doubt is
what haunts our dreams it creates a
crack in our facade it destabilizes the
fundamental character structure in the
house of cards that steadies our
temperament for doubt invites the
disquiet that maybe we don't know
anything and holy we are hurled
into chaos and uncertainty and so we
cling hand me the cross give me the Star
of David pass me the bhagavad-gita turn
on that new youtuber preacher dude like
we're all looking for something to hold
on to and something to believe in and I
suppose I have sympathy for our
situation I too and looking for the song
that resonates with truth and the
infectiousness of the unconflicted man
and in the end perhaps it doesn't matter
if those that we find so alluring are
actually speaking of some kind of
objective truth for maybe that's not the
point maybe it's just a fiction we can
believe in that we need in order to move
about with grace and equanimity
so
yeah
that explains our well it explains the
irresistible pull and the infectiousness
of the unconvicted man